The Joe Rogan experience,
you should eat.
So Matt, you really
should, you should eat,
you should eat some animal
protein without, I mean,
if you oppose the moral
aspect of killing an animal,
which I totally understand and appreciate,
and that's what led me to become a hunter
in the first places that I was really
uncomfortable watching these animal
rights videos of factory farming.
I thought it was disgusting.
I'm just like,
I don't want to participate
in this is reprehensible.
Hunting's a different thing, man.
To me, hunting is this intense.
It's very spiritual in a way.
I mean,
people don't get it because they see you
celebrating when it's over because it's
very, very, very difficult
to close in on a wild animal.
Mostly elk. Well, Alex, my favorite for
two reasons. One, it's very delicious,
super nutritious. Also, if I shoot one
elk, I could eat it for like eight months.
What you deliver? Yeah, freezing them
breathing. So you're out
stalk in an elk on the plains.
Where are you like near where you live?
You just go to our travel.
How'd you can,
yeah. When you do travel on bikes,
if you're a white tail hunt,
a lot of times would go into the woods
with bikes cause they don't leave a scent
the way your feet do, you know? And um,
animals don't associate the sound of a
bike the way they associate with like the
sound of stepping by peatal Holland.
Yeah.
Slapping 12 evolve, right? Oh
yeah. They see you on a bike.
They didn't even freak out
as much. Delightful. Never
seen that. Like what's that?
My brain. What are these things?
Yeah, yeah. Oh are they hurt animals?
So you just see like a herd.
Yeah,
yeah.
You see a herd of them and try to figure
out which way the wind's blowing and
you try to get close to them.
Is this a video of us? Yeah.
This is a video house from,
Oh yeah, that's on elk now.
The thing is you've made,
I see that elk there and I sort of
feel like I've watched too much Disney.
Um, you know, like I see that elk and
I feel I'm Bambi literally, you know,
like I don't have it. Like is that early
in the morning you look tired? Not Tired.
My no late afternoon actually. Can you
tell if it was late afternoon? Yeah.
Like say it like I from that
position I couldn't breathe.
Like I would love the game of being able
to him because actually I've had to go
down.
Gun Range is,
it turns out I'm pretty good shot and
it's nice to see that thing come back with
like holes around his abdomen and
his head and I think satisfied there.
You've been dealt with paper man.
But, but like the ILC I couldn't,
I've got too much empathy in me that I
couldn't deal with the feeling of after
it was shot. I like it. They
like almost thinking about it,
the sentimentality of it. I've
sentimentalize it now, you know,
at least I don't eat
meat and stuff like that.
So it's not like I have all those feelings
of bat can handle it in a packaged
portioned off way. It's just like
feel too much like, oh that creature.
So what in your head when you're doing it,
when you're pulling the trigger,
you're not having what's
going on in your mind.
Well,
you,
you only are hunting these mature
animals that have already passed on their
genes.
You also are recognizing that if you're
not killing these things, they're not,
it's not like they're going to live
forever. They are, they live a short life,
a short life with a very violent death.
It's either wolves or mountain lions or
bears or something's going to take them
out.
Yeah.
And what you're doing is essentially
dipping your toe into the natural world.
And I've heard the argument that,
well,
this is ridiculous because
everyone can't do that. You know,
if everyone went out and hunted all the
animals, so it'd be no animals slept,
which is true. But, um, I'm not
everyone. And so I don't, you know,
I mean to use that, if everyone
did he argument, it's a
good argument because you,
if you're encouraging people to hunt,
it is kind of a good argument because
it's not realistic. It's not sustainable.
But the other thing to recognize is that
the reason why most of this wildlife
exist in the first place.
A lot of it was wiped out in
the early 20th century from um,
what they call market hunting
and the late, late 19th
century, early 20th century.
Um, they, you know, they didn't
have refrigeration and uh,
it was hard to get food and we didn't
have the same sort of large scale
agriculture that we have today.
And so when someone would want meat,
they would,
uh,
someone who would either have to hunt it
for you and you'd go to the market and
get that hunted food or a,
you would go out and do it yourself.
And they basically wiped out most of the
wildlife in North America to the point
of extinction, whitetail deer, elk,
they've been extra painted from the
majority of their range in North American,
only been replaced and a few other places,
but the places would,
they have been replaced.
It's all through money that was generated
through hunting tags all through
billions and billions of dollars. There's
a thing called the a Robertson Pickman,
I think that's what it's called,
act where a 10%,
if you buy hunting gear and equipment,
10% of that money goes to
habitat restoration. Um,
making sure that a rangers
and forest people get funded.
So there's a fish and game department
gets funded and all and also population
conservation, making sure that
the populations are healthy,
repopulating certain
areas with elk and deer.
And this has all been done through the
money that's generated through hunting.
Yeah, I can see that there's an
looking at my own feelings towards it.
I can see that there's a,
potentially I'm bringing
a center mentality to the
idea of animals that's like
anthropomorphic. Yes. Like I'm not, oh
you can't kill that. It will abate babies.
And I mean like thinking about things
like that. Um, but what I, you know,
I live in a rural area in Britain where
like hunting is normal and I wouldn't,
and agriculture is normal and I wouldn't
get very far if I were sort of like,
you can't shoot those pheasants, look
at their feathers, they're beautiful.
You know what I mean? Like it
wouldn't, it's not a helpful attitude.
So whilst I like record in my cell,
I couldn't do that because like it
messes me up on a sort of a field,
like a very sort of deep
visceral level, you know, like,
but I feel like this is precisely the
kind of territory we have to look at
acknowledging and tolerate
indifference between us.
This is where I feel like the sort of
these ossified polarized positions between
right and left are starting to take root
because if someone like me who don't
eat meat, don't eat animal products
and wooden hunt for ethical reasons,
start trying to impose on other people
now you shouldn't harm because of this
that I've not watched Bambi,
you know,
like that's going to mean that people
aren't able to explore who they are.
And so my po,
I've let go of judging people around
things that I don't agree with because my
record, I don't know everything. You
know what I mean? I'm this, this is like,
this is about my morality is about how
I behave. And if people said to me,
I'm thinking about going hunting, I go,
well these are my feelings about it.
However though I just heard
that hunting does contribute.
Apparently that is survival to some
species and there is an argument that it's
quite natural in indigenous and it's
probably a way of getting in contact with
who we are originally as hunt in
people is an important part of our
anthropological history and possibly a
lot of the condemnation of hunt in his
part of the rejection of who we used
to be is we become overly civilized and
more and more detached from
what it is to be human.
Whether that's sacred or pragmatic, we
don't know what human beings are anymore.
We reject our own sexuality, we reject
our own bodies, we reject, you know,
we're trying to turn ourselves in these
sort of cyborgs, these emotionless,
sexless, meaningless creatures.
Where is our passion?
Whereas our connection with the
sacred, they would go, hold on.
Only after about hunting in,
when are you going to stop talking?
Never gave me an in.
I will pummel you with my belief
system on all things like, you know,
so I don't feel like that ain't
where I get into judging people.